yeah welcome to this video i just won a
game after eight moves by disconnection
so i'm not going to upload that you can
see there was just some some moves off
ruh lopez exchange theory and I'm I put
out a seek for a new game game and start
here we go against another player from
Turkey sin sin and gave her rated about
2,000 your the Turkish players always
are not always but there you need to be
a bit a bit cautious they are very often
you have young players very young
players because turkey has made huge
progress with chats and schools and they
have a ton of promising juniors so on it
can easily happen that you play very
talented player right to d7 here
interesting interesting yeah taking it
is not really helping me 95 is the
normal move down one of the normal moves
hmm okay I spent too much time already
on this before I might take on sea foam
I don't want a gambit you get the type
of plane that it's not it's not
necessary really but this is already
already quite okay for black I guess
interesting this only 97 really throwing
a bit of a spanner in the works okay
then we then I must player this type of
position which is not too exciting the
bishop on a six is of course nicely
placed and that means that black has
solved his main problem which is usually
this bishop he's reroute into a five not
sure that this is leading to much but I
understand that the night on g7 wasn't
great but I probably would have just
taken just probably just put it on f6
but okay not not a bad bad setup I
wonder i should play before maybe him
it's got Bishop c4
yeah I really don't have any active play
in this position this 97 interesting
really interesting
after Bishop c4 I'm playing me for this
was my idea and I can take d5 this is
why I thought this wasn't possible 95 or
Bishop g5 yeah come on let's let's play
one of those yeah maybe you can take on
d5 and then then play some some Bishop
move some discovered move but that takes
c6 all the time so we cannot let they
take on g3 he just retreats it but now I
have 93 right taking here and if the but
it cannot move to e6 because of d5 yeah
I think he just blundered t5 he had a
very nice position before so openly with
the very decent chances ok let's let's
push also Queen D for 3d for whom we can
put something on your five so I should
first take here and now Queen him
threatening made and threatening see
form so I'm getting this pawn oh I
forgot about Bishop move the fisherman's
yeah this was very unnecessary from
completely completely winning position
to this year okay well I've got two
pawns it's not necessarily not yet these
six check the eyes it's got this check
on b1 and son den and f2 attacked hmm
yeah I know it looks like a passive move
but I'm thinking yeah d6 check no don't
don't have enough time to really
calculate stuff here
these seven does III jack III not with
the check I actually forgot that he's
got green e63 e6 no queen e cigs
ah that's a shame
I was I was like in the game again rly
time warning well no I know is playing
chat I'm of course check position is not
sure maybe it's winning for him can
maybe a soup Swami my bishop him ok
they're playing applying a this defense
really badly back against God's I've got
66 seconds white person ah that's really
it's a pest at the moment completely
over this game of course can I can for
instance player for why he's got no
movie at all i takes you four next move
this is still keeping a big edge but
it's not not as convincing of course so
let's see i'm still winning here plus
two according to the comp quincy for
check and Quincy five wins yeah this is
not winning the problem is Queenie
signal course I forgot about that check
your even this is winning check and the
deep bone is very strong and I'm
attacking a seven of course this is also
totally unnecessary if you I just I just
forgot about the bishop e5 move I was
not really a looking looking anymore and
the worst is that even this is winning
check
yeah with this coming and andy sixx
completely completely gone yeah this was
a strange thing here why is this working
that is not working I can take you yeah
earlier I was really a bit stunned by
this move because they all play Bishop
e7 here and then I can take of course
yeah now I see it after take I can take
care of course and if he takes on e5 I
can just take here and that's still take
undefined because of the work so I could
have went could have one on move nine
already yeah yeah yeah what the heck
thanks for watching